naja das ist auch wieder nur so ein baum
pilz damit kann ich nichts anfangen
komme ich nicht mehr richtig mein messer
durch so hartes der
wenig wegen trockene böden der sommer
2018 hat auch im wald seine spuren
hinterlassen
für pilzsammler vitamin c ist das
besonders bitter
ja dieses jahr war bisher noch nichts
also ich gehe jetzt schon ein paar jahre
in die pilze aber so wenig wie im moment
habe ich bisher selten erlebt also ich
meine wir hatten jetzt den trockensten
august haben jetzt irgendwie den
heißesten september seit beginn der
wetteraufzeichnungen da ist es klar dass
da nicht viele pilze nase
das problem mit der trockenheit kennt
auch franz heller
seit 25 jahren führt der pilzexperte
interessierte durch den wald wiesbadener
umweltladen berät er einmal in der woche
pilzsammler zu ihren kunden
auch wenn diese derzeit eher mickrig
ausfallen
der größte feind der pilze ist die
trockenheit und zwar was mir hier hinten
ist ja nur der bruch gabe wie der
abgelaufenen baum
das pils mit cdu wächst und ehrlich im
grasboden im waldboden oder bei den
dingen also die steinpilze artigen
knicks 10 15 meter tief drin
das kann es passieren dass in zehn
zentimeter tiefe noch feuchtigkeit ist
das heißt steinpilze komm raus alle an
ein pilze die im laub wachsen kommen zum
beispiel nicht aus in trockenen zeiten
wie diesen sätzen pilzsammler deshalb
gerne auf ihre erfahrung ein ganz guter
tipp das ist auch immer dazu gucken wo
muss ist weil das speichert das wasser
so ein bisschen aber man sieht selbst
dass es im moment richtig trocken
experte franz eller kennt noch weitere
tipps
man sollte auf jeden fall mit auf die
südtangente ist gebirgig ist also berge
da sind nicht auf die südhänge sondern
auf die nordtangente renz geht war die
nicht von der sonne beschienen
und sollte auf jeden fall immer darauf
achten viele berge haben können ganz
einfach mal was er unterläuft und
irgendwann muss es ja irgendwann mitte
herauslaufen und das sieht man in dem
wenn man darauf achtet wenn man ein
spazieren geht und achte darauf wo ist
es noch grün
wo wächst noch was und wo schon alles
vertrocknet
das geht gar nicht unbedingt immer ein
steinpilz sein oder so aber irgendetwas
zu finden wäre dann doch ganz schön
jedem pilze sammeln geht erst mal durch
den kopf
steinpilz für welling marrone rothkamm
das geht zuerst durch den kopf mit dem
können wir momentan in mengen noch nicht
dienen
ja wir müssen auf die konzentrieren die
jetzt da sind und es gibt viele pilze
wenn man aufstellen geht die noch
einigermaßen feucht sind doch selbst für
edelpilze ist es noch nicht zu spät
versicherte lahm
die pilzsaison 2018 schreibt er noch
lange nicht ab wenn der regen jetzt
kommt haben wir in 14 tage eine baum
schwerer als ein pilz wirkung weil man
muss sich das vorstellen das dauert ja
auch eine zeitlang das myzel hat zwar
unsere knospen ausgebildet wo die
fruchtkörper entstehen und rauch und
feuchtigkeit um sich zu strecken
der steilküste so klein ist ist in einer
woche so also das geht verhältnismäßig
schnell nur die feuchtigkeit fehlen
sollte es dennoch hart auf hart kommt
hat der passionierte pilzsammler per se
ein tipp für seine leidensgenossen parat
wenn das wetter jetzt weiter so bleibt
dann gibt es ja zum glück auch ein paar
sorten die man züchten kann und dann
wird man als echter pilz freund auch im
supermarkt findet